no matter who wins on sunday there will
be a post super bowl celebration
so we teamed up with verizon to get you
all the details on their big concert
for small businesses
tell me about the concert after the game
i'm looking forward to the big concert
for small businesses
particularly miley cyrus is a favorite
of ours and christina aguilera and you
know eric church and
luke ryan and we're just so excited that
artists are coming together with verizon
business to
support small businesses it just means
so much to our community
the big concert for small businesses
kicks off verizon's mission to support
one million small businesses by 2030.
the company is also donating 10 million
dollars in small business
grants to help entrepreneurs like
florida brewery owners matthew and danny
who were impacted by the pandemic that's
dedication that's getting involved in
your local
organizations and businesses and
thinking about sustainability in general
for the mass communities
how is verizon helping small businesses
with their 5g network
technology plays such a huge role in
creating that sense of community
so just having that technology the
connectivity
um the 5g to get the messages out there
update our menu update our website keep
our customers engaged
and in the know how they can get their
[Music]
beer